Kiev this morning and Russia's answer to
the West yes usually to uh to
where was it
not far away
you never get used to that no
in total 55 Rockets were directed
towards Ukraine today more than 10
people died the biggest air offensive
for a fortnight
most of the missiles were intercepted
but some evaded the country's air
defense Dome
yesterday president zielinski walked the
corridors of the dimly lit presidential
Palace and warned that Putin is
preparing for a new even deadlier
assault Mr President there's talk of a
Russian surge coming soon
when do you think that might be and how
prepared are you
um
foreign
country with heavy Firepower in the form
of challenges Abrams and leopard tanks
their reports suggest delivery could
take weeks if not months perhaps now is
the time to talk peace do you ever
wonder what might happen if you were in
a room alone with President Putin would
that help at all to resolve this war
not interesting for me
not interesting to meet
not interesting to speak
why because we had meeting with him in
Normandy format it was before the
full-scale invasion
I saw
the man who said one thing and then did
another is it too late now
too late not interesting who is he now
after full-scale Invasion for me he's
nobody
um nobody his comments just go and use
infuriated Moscow
boys
from critics in the Kremlin Furious
zelenski referring to the Russian leader
as a nobody to somebody who is a
somebody to you is Boris Johnson would
you like to see him have an official
public role as a UK Envoy to Ukraine
official who who will be I don't know
he an embassy he will be ambassador from
Britain in Ukraine it was pleasure
I was pleasure he's a good guy and I'm
I'm not I'm not sure that he's ready for
such status because no but who knows I
mean that to his pleasure was pleasure I
saw Johnson in different situations I
saw him in not in war and then in
full-scale war that's why we have
special relations
zelenski's closest ties though are with
his family
the president told of private moments he
shares with his son
conversations not about playground
Antics but about Battleground offensives
it's the tragedy that they
they speak about it not about children's
not about their you know games between
each other not about soccer yes no no
dialogues about soccer no that is the
difference
but we will we will change this
situation